well this was earlier today during
pregame ceremonies and as we make our
official return to baseball tonight some
players from each team showing support
black lives matter movement to eradicate
systemic racism and the unnecessary use
of force against black people in policy
well joe ben's going to see if he can
bring his winning ways
to the angels as the athletics take the
field for the first time for real here
in 2020
and for frankie montos last september
against these angels and tonight's
starting pitcher andrew heaney he
started for the angels in that game
frankie with the 80-game suspension last
year came back very strongly in
september and i think he was motivated
by that david fletcher leads it off for
the hand lois fletcher
there's and he is there he does not
strike out very much but he does there
chases a pitch way out of the strike
zone well this is this is what you want
to see from frankie montos and i talked
about it a little earlier today he gets
to two strikes and he is pedaled to the
metal he's looking to punch you out and
put you away
shogi otani at the plate he's de-h
tonight good lead for trout at first
three one that's lined up to center
field that's gonna fall in for a base
hit trout will advance to second he'll
stop there first hit of the season for
the angels and upton will come to the
play with two on another 3-2 to justin
upton runners staying put strike three
called on the inside corner
until they're loaded up for albert
pujols no score top of the first the
angel is threatening bases are loaded
albert 244 last year swinging i missed
struck him out on a high fastball and it
looked like pujols may have chased ball
three so frankie montos has to work a
little extra hard but the angels leave
them loaded simeon lauriano and chapman
against the left-hander andrew heaney
who because of a couple of stints on the
dl last year pitched in just 18 games
easy out marcus simeon retired here's
ramon
lariano the center fielder
payoff got him looking got the express
right down broadway
two down this is chad pinder the second
baseman with two outs of nobody on
fender skies one
playable
tom de la stella drifting out into
shadow right brian goodwin and
eventually calls him off la stella never
heard him a little bit of a collision
there everyone's all right
get away from him
fend for yourself trout says oh no we're
good can't do that here's often struck
out looking in the first he's the leg
kick the pitch swung on bouncing ball
deep short down to an ego simeon to his
right goes the short way they force
ohtani a second and the inning is over
no runs or
hits runners here in the spa game just
haven't been able to get anyone home two
more on here and brian goodwin will bat
with two gone two on with two outs good
one rips one into right field that's
gonna get down for a base hit biscotti
comes up with it pujols coming around to
score and the angels have a one-nothing
lead as good was caught in a rundown
jason castro trying to come home he's
going to get tagged out the angel's got
albert's run but the inning ends on that
throw to home plate one nothing angel's
lead andrew heeney's been very good
ramon lauriano now babson
left field and deep
and
that baby's gone we're tied
24 home runs a year ago for laureano
and he collects the a's first
of the 60-game sprint of 2020. joe
madden went to the bullpen to replace
hiney who was fishing well and
immediately ramirez comes on he walks
the first two batters biscotti and
murphy loading the bases for simeon
here comes the 3-1
this one
shadow left field mark angela simmons
going out there
hello
hello he was just trying to keep us uh
keep us watching yeah and exhale there
90 feet away from scoring the go-ahead
run and now with one ounce you have the
ace play they'll draw the infield in
and here comes the pesky david fletcher
fletcher lifts one out toward right
center field
oriano is there simmons will tag at
third
he'll come in to score the angels have
themselves a 2-1 lead clutcher with his
first rbi that's called productive
hitting
and so simeon works a walk and the a's
have the tying run on base with one out
of the bottom of the eighth and l'oreal
is coming up he is moving and the ball
is lying fair down the right field line
simeon digging for third the ball is
kicked around by goodwin here comes
marcus simeon he's gonna score we're
tied at two
brian goodwin went into a slide
but did not come up with it cleanly
and once
the ball kind of rolled away from him
just a little bit but he had to go
retrieve it and at that point simeon was
going to score
and now chapman's coming up and the
go-ahead run is in scoring position
that one's driven to right it's hit well
goodwin going back goodwin at the wall
goodwin leaps it's over his head
lorianna was standing at second base
he's got a hustling rounds third being
waved home he's going to score chapman
the third of these have the lead so matt
chapman goes the other way just like
laureato did
and chapman with the rbi triple so the
a's lead it three to two it is the top
of the ninth inning the closer liam
hendricks comes in so here is jason
castro and that one is lifted high in
the air and that ball is carrying pretty
well into right field and it is gone
a home run jason castro has just tied up
the ball game with one out here
in the top of the ninth inning first
home run as a halo 13 home run versus
right-handed pitching his first of the
year versus the right-handed pitcher
marcus
skying the first one castro might have a
play on it he does so we'll head to the
10th the new rule will be in effect
they'll be a runner
placed at second base hey buddy you're
at second base new rules this year so as
long as this game goes on every half
inning there will be a runner at second
base last out of the previous sitting
will take his place at second base 2-2
walsh pulls onto the right side olson
goes to third picked by chapman to have
shohein a rundown
so that's going to be a fielder's choice
johay too far away from second base
there the left-hand hitting matt olson
no place to go but home davis at first
l'oriano at second the placed runner the
bottom of the tent marcus simeon is at
third infield outfield will play in next
with the goal with the five infielders
still milliner's sidewinder his first
pitch breaky ball drill deep right this
game is over how far is it gonna go it
will clear the seats it's a grand slam
what a way to walk off opening night for
matt olson
didn't waste a moment and see you later
this historic night of major league
baseball in extra innings
and the a's walk off the angels